[Music]
early this year will and I were talking
about battlefield and Call of Duty years
as a franchise but both these franchises
now have a new shooter on the block so
we're going to be talking about what
makes it different what makes them
appealing what kind of experience
they're going to give now I know you've
been playing quite a bit of quite duty
over the past few weeks I have I've
always been more of a Call of Duty guy
and black ops 4 does feel for me a
little bit like a return to form in
terms of the multiplayer especially in
terms of like poor Call of Duty gameplay
and then how you could compare that to
battery or I guess Call of Duty feels
more intense smaller Maps fewer people
is very like twitch twitch Iver e quick
and I've got to admit I have a hard time
keeping up these days I definitely an
unmanned yeah I feel like an old man
playing Call of Duty now and and
sometimes with some of them score
streaks which are ridiculous that drones
just come out and start murdering you
I'm like oh this isn't fun anymore but I
guess that's always been you know the I
guess Marriott's blue shell to coochies
first-person shooter you get a blue
shell for when you're bad but that's a
negative feedback loop is that that's
what America has it has a negative
feedback or you as a positive feedback
loop the better you do the better you do
yeah yeah it's once you're on a roll you
really are on a roll
Danny Boy
but I really like what they're doing
with some of the specialists right so
they've sort of taken elements from hero
shooters and tried to apply that to a
Call of Duty game so when you start
around you pick your specialist which is
essentially a character who has special
abilities it might be a dart that you
fire and it has a sensor on it so it
tells you where enemies are it might be
a special weapon it might be a dog that
you can set off after people so that
does bring a new flavor to Call of Duty
and I think that keeps it fresh because
if it didn't have these new elements
that have obviously been inspired by the
games
it might just feel like same old Call of
Duty that is feels very very different
to Battlefield you've been playing a
bunch of and I think you're more of a
battlefield player anyway yeah I've
always been leaning towards the the
battlefield campus play a lot of college
Yui back in the day but similarly my
time with with black ops 4 I just feel a
little bit like an old man but the the
way that each them play considering the
voice when put head-to-head I think this
time these two games is so polar by
playing Call of Duty as people dolphin
diving and jumping around corners right
in your face yeah battlefields a little
slower little more strategic little more
thoughtful and that's what I've wanted
but I'm saying that it's got it's got a
variety in the gameplay just within if
you do a grand operations day one might
be long open stretches to fight over and
then day two you getting like really
intense urban combat so you've got that
variety there but the biggest thing for
me the biggest thing that's sold
battlefield 5 for me this year is is the
emphasis of episodes of squad play
that's always been what sold battlefield
for me the feeling that you and three or
four other players can really make a
difference and around depending on how
you work together yeah okay funny a
funny day I got
no you haven't
the attrition system means that you need
to keep together because your supplies
are lower you're you only get like one
bandage you don't heal to full anymore
so it means medics and support classes
are now more useful when you're
defending your position your support can
actually build barricades as that's
that's it feels amazing there's that
there's a sensation I was telling you
about before there's when you're playing
airborne and you're waiting for the
enemy to come as soon as you spawn
everyone's just running to the points
like just building stuff up throwing up
sandbags putting up gun turrets and then
there's a real like eerie moment of calm
where you're seeing the the paratrooper
planes coming forward and then all of a
sudden flak cannons just start opening
up and shooting at them then parachutes
come out you see all these enemies like
just run through the tree line mowing
them down it's it's a game that feels
like a war movie it has those like
organic set pieces almost they feel if
this was in any of the game it would
like someone script of this someone
created this to give so give the moment
that the feeling that I'm feeling in
this moment no matter what you do no
matter what class you're playing you
feel like I can be useful
mmm not only can I perform well
individually but I could be really
useful as part of like the machine that
makes up my team yeah there's definitely
a sense of camaraderie and and opposed
to Call of Duty where you're on earth
team but I still feel like I'm just by
myself just running trying to get kills
and I'm sure you can have teamwork but
it doesn't really work as well as
battlefield no it playing like Search
and Destroy and Call of Duty where
that'sthat's of all the modes that's
that's one you feel like you need team
works one life you could stick together
plant the bomb but everyone has runs
runs everyone that's like AI kill
whereas battlefield it's not rewarding
kills you get rewarded for kills but
that's not the primary reward you can
get you can out point a player by not
killing people I was playing last night
and the guy at the top of our school
board had like four kills and a bunch of
deaths and he was the top because he was
just like he was fully I'll be your hero
baby running at people I
chucking smoke grenades down stabbing
everyone with adrenaline syringes and
honestly that guy kept our back line
secure so it's that one it's that
feeling that battlefield gives you this
like yes you can make a difference and
you can you can be that hero baby
so let's talk about modes because that's
another big difference with these two
games Call of Duty has multiplayer there
has zombies and it has blackout which is
the Battle Royale and they've stripped
away single-player this year which is a
bit for me was was weird because I love
the single-player campaigns in Call of
Duty yeah but what about battlefield how
are they doing things this time straight
of the box you get the war stories and
then the multiplayer with its plethora
of modes and then you at the start at
the core launch the tides of war will
start where it will drip feed you
content going forward you get the
firestorm and all that but day one
you'll get all the mods player and the
war stories
it's the party beautiful
I know the lack of single player was a
bit of a sticking point in ecology II
like you said battlefield 5 has taken
tones from battlefield 1 where they're
taking individual stories rather than
one campaign and this time it's it's
stories that have kind of out of the the
public I really like intimate ones
character-driven I've only play the
first two Africa and Norway but but my
favorite thing is that it's it's the
story part war story I'm not gonna lie
and say the AI is amazing or you're
gonna get like incredible a
single-player experience its competent
it's entertaining but go into it
expecting a story go into expecting to
learn something and have a feeling of
like wow I didn't I didn't know this was
a thing I didn't know that that that I
didn't know about the SBS I didn't know
about this stuff happening in Norway
that that's really what I was I was left
with war stories then multiplayer we
don't actually don't have our version of
battle royale firestorm yet but for me
the multiplayer modes that they've been
like really diverse considering you know
that they're going to be similar
whichever way you look at it it's one
team fighting another but the difference
is in the way it plays between airborne
and breakthrough and conquest and even
if you just want to play a team
deathmatch for domination then that's
there too
the most part in multiplayer feels like
Call of Duty has its has its core
classic modes and then the big new shiny
look at this thing is the yeah yeah I
I'm excited to see firestorm when that
when that arrives for battlefield so I
do love battle hell games and I was
super excited to see it come to call of
duty well my favorite things about it
was that previous battle rail games I
had felt a bit like I'm not very good at
this I can't Street people I panic all
the time the great thing about blackout
is it still a Call of Duty game so you
jump out and you land and it controls
that Call of Duty so I felt like I was
hitting the ground running rather than
just flailing around shooting in the sky
know what I was doing
it's not up there you know as the best
battle rail game out they think but it
scratches that itch we talked about the
Battle Royale
Jean well well most specifically black
out this fortnight
mmm we went into detail on that if you
want to check out that video but we said
it's it's very accessible that's right
yeah but why I'm glad that battlefield
is launching their battle royale later
cuz it feels like people are going to
get an opportunity to experience
battlefield at its core people are
experiencing it now are going to learn
they're gonna be prepared especially
with a new way the battlefield 5 plays
with in 4 squad mechanics the attrition
the building that's going to lend itself
to firestorm 3 battlefield is more of a
sophisticated dinner we're cooler due to
second or you can eat buffet where
you're rubbing elbows with people but
that I mentioned zombies because that's
another battlefield
no no zombies I know people love zombies
in Call of Duty I've dabbled in it and I
dropped into this one and there's a lot
going on there's like different classes
and abilities and potions and I was a
bit out of my depth if I'm honest but
there's a lot there for people who like
a zombies mode and I think there's a lot
of replayability and a lot of character
in that as well it has its own sort of
mini story going on yeah
and so yeah I really like the variety
that that cods is offering but it feels
like battlefield has more succumbs
that's also exciting yeah I'm on things
bear in mind as well as if if you're
someone that can only play short bursts
of games or they want to experience the
game in very short bursts or they want
that reward cornered you he's probably
going to give you that because the
rounds in college give you a lot quicker
average rounded way under ten minutes
whereas I played a game battlefield last
night and I think I aged like three or
four years it was like an hour and a
half long when was the war it was it was
amazing Christ that's got a better for
that
so we have two big shooters to choose
from Dave which would you recommend and
who for if you're someone that ones
they're like instant gratification they
may have that much time or just want a
more arcadey experience and if you want
to play a batter out game like now then
college is gonna be for you if you want
something that you want to invest a lot
of time in that you want to learn that
you want these longer games and these
these great experiences and if you want
squad play like if you've already got
three friends they've got battlefield 5
get battlefield 5 because even if this
game isn't for you I guarantee playing
with those three will sell it for you
you'll get you'll get to feel that squad
play and that team work if you're on the
larger scale if you want the team work
the vehicles the bigger maps then I'd go
for battlefield for me it's been a much
more rewarding experience but over time
whereas Call of Duty has been rewarding
like instantly like winning games
winning games go go go shoot shoot shoot
Cody is the quick fix and it's larger
than life I like it in in small chunks
you've got grappling hooks you've got
crazy weapons it's it's really out there
but I think thinking about it actually
battlefield might be the gamer I'd
rather play long-term and get more
serious about no doubt plenty of you out
there have already played at least one
of the other so feel free to let us know
your thoughts in the comment section
below
or you can find me on twitter at a
regular Dave or bill at the quiff is
dead
make sure you send me your origin ID
because I need more people to squad up
with because my medic let me down last
night anyway see you in that episode
[Music]